i know you're not sensitive i know
you're like everything that has happened
in my life happened and
i was looking for all these things but
what is the thing that they could talk
about in winning time that you're like
i'd be portrayed in a bad light here i
maybe goes wrong here i don't care and i
understand that i don't care i don't
know i don't care
there's not a thing you're like yeah
people are going to think i even though
you don't care there has to be a moment
in your career like this probably
as a leader you have to do
and say certain things to get your
troops to respond to a certain level
i don't know i don't care but guess what
it
ain't that bad i'm not in jail
i'm sitting here talking to to vanessa
rooks
so
it's gonna catch on okay i'm telling you
it is absolutely vanessa rooks
doesn't work but the name vanessa though
i know people are gonna tweet me like
girl what are you talking about and
that's fine that's fair um
on the um subject of the lakers and
winning time definitely have to talk to
you about that you know jeannie bus
obviously came out today and talked
about
all the money that she spent on the team
and she felt like it obviously failed
and she's um upset about that what are
your words to genie best i love genie
bus i would never have anything bad to
say about me she's great or the best
family yeah
it's business sometimes you make
investments they work out and they don't
we we move on
i'm not here to criticize miss busting
she should have did this she i don't
know i don't know what she should have
done just miss jeannie i'll support you
i love you hope you and rob get it
together and
bring us back to prominence because the
problem with us la fans was spoiled yeah
we're used to having the top players we
used to go into the final we used to win
a championship and when you don't get
that
people go crazy she knows that she
understands that's why she
lebron haiti
carmelo
westbrook because we used to have big
names play together and work together
but this time it didn't work but
it's okay genie